Leading by example.
But as Brazil's president tucked into home-produced meat...
...to try to allay fears about hygiene,...
...the international impact of a corruption scandal in the industry is growing.
For as Michel Temer took foreign diplomats to a steakhouse,...
...China and South Korea suspended some imports...
...and the EU mulled actions of its own against Brazilian meat.
The commission is in the process of ensuring...
...that any of the establishments implicated in the fraud...
...are suspended from exporting in the EU.
Police are probing claims that health inspectors were bribed...
...to overlook unsanitary conditions at several plants...
...in a scandal that's tarnished Brazil's lucrative meat industry.
Authorities insist there's no sanitary risk,...
...despite allegations that some producers have sold rotten and tampered meat products.
Police conducted raids on Friday and more than 30 people were arrested.
The firms involved deny any wrongdoing,...
...but the scandal deals a big blow to one of the few sectors in Brazil...
...that's thrived during two years of recession.